in the lobby of Ramsey solutions one of
our favorite that free screams one of
our own team members Josh is with us and
his wife Claire hey guys how are you
welcome I should say almost one of our
new team members you've been with this
one about eight months or so is that
about right yes sir very cool well very
fine and so you've been working on this
debt free stuff before you got here
obviously how much of YouTube paid off
we've paid off sixty nine thousand five
hundred dollars in about 19 months all
right and about half of that time is
here yes okay okay cool
very cool and I want to ask your income
now because your team members are all
standing around and and you're in sales
but they probably could figure it out if
you're selling anything but anyway the
before you came here what was your
office household income we start out
around 50,000 averaged through at around
60 okay all right very cool good and so
since you've moved here Claire's gotten
a position life's good I assume what are
you doing Claire I'm an event florist in
downtown Franklin I do weddings and
parties and stuff like that she's my
child there you go he's used that before
yeah every weekend he drops that
somewhere that's good good line all
right cool what kind of debt was the
70,000 would you people buy well we
started off with some students we got a
car 28 and a half oh nice car would you
buy a truck a Jeep Grand Cherokee
Overland oh I'm thinking this is
Claire's she was my baby your baby did
did the baby get sold sold
I liked the air-conditioned seats yeah
yeah that's pretty sweet yeah it's a fun
car it really is but you got rid of it
you amputated the Cherokee then we had
another personal loan that was about
five thousand okay all right so selling
that helped part of the equation I guess
yes all right what are you driving now
we drive a 2011 Infiniti sorry I try to
make it newer than what it felt it felt
better when you said it I don't know
one car you're sharing one no I also
drive a little truck okay all right all
right so you you went from a Cherokee to
an o1 Infiniti yeah that was real that
was real we're not kidding around now
Wow very cool so obviously we know when
you're on this team that there's a lot
of positive peer pressure a lot of folks
on the team working this so it's kind of
an easy environment in the sense of a
lot of cheerleaders cheering you on but
before that obviously have y'all been
married just actually we started our
journey right after we got me out so
we've got 20 months okay
so you come home from the honeymoon side
you're gonna do this how did you get
connected to this stuff originally since
you weren't working here at the time and
tell me the story of how this all
happened so it kind of started one of my
co-workers where I used to work was
doing fu classes and you really
encouraged me that I should also do it
and I knew I've been falling a little
bit of the principles beforehand but it
was kind of piecemeal things that I
thought that I could apply and not
everything and then I decided you know
what I should lead a class and I should
always so lead my household through this
and so I said Claire I really want to do
this would you you know come with me and
host a class with me so we just jumped
in you know both feet did an FPU class
at a local library I had about ten
people show up the first time and it was
great yeah did two other classes after
that and then just stuck with it and
really got passionate about sharing this
mission okay very cool and you did that
immediately after getting married yes
Wow okay
very cool very cool well I mean
obviously Josh you're one of our smart
dollar sellers one of the guys working
with companies around America keep
putting smart dollar in as a as an a
benefit for teams and we've got about a
million people doing that you're one of
the reasons now our million employees
now have access to smart dollar that'd
be a proper way of saying that and so
you get to talk to people every day
about this stuff but what do you to when
your friends say you know seventy
thousand bucks and they say how did you
do that what do you tell him I'll say
for me it was definitely communicating
with Claire that this was something that
you know if we didn't do this now then
we couldn't live out our dreams in the
future
and just keeping that in mind and saying
once we start communicating that these
are things we want to do in our life and
things that we want to give to other
people if we just kind of get out of
debt then we can do all those things and
do without any guilt or shame or fear
around it and that's the thing that I
think powered my you know personality
and then also the budget the budget is
huge and that's the communication tool
that helps it and I'm a numbers guy I
came from an advising role financial
advisor beforehand and so I would do it
in my head but never communicated on
paper and that was huge for me to say to
Claire you know this is what we agree to
and this is what I want you know to
share with you do you agree and then yes
she's definitely the free spirit yeah I
definitely needed it too just so we
could go through the numbers together
and I have to physically see it on paper
yeah so for him to be able to just sit
down and let's go over everything
together that made the biggest
difference yeah absolutely so Claire you
hi I know Josh well enough to know he
didn't come in strong handed and go
Cherokee's leaving since he didn't do
this how did you come to the how did you
cuz you had to come to the conclusion I
know to sell that so how did that happen
I mean tell me about that night we were
actually at your conference it was the
smart money to her in national yeah in
October oh yes here yeah and actually I
was just kind of sitting there and I was
thinking to myself us like why am i
letting this car hold us back from all
the people and all the things that we
could be doing all the many blessings
and I was just like this is just so
silly of me and so finally we've just
kind of thought to myself well if we get
rid of it we could just save up money
later and pay for another one in all
cash so it's like just get rid of it
just like that yeah so finally I just
kind of like put my like selfishness
aside and yeah I'll say that I was
dadgum smart money conference just cause
more powers to be sorry Chris Hogan
actually did it the big pop story where
he started talking about how he wanted
to you know take his kids to Disneyland
and
thing and it's the big pop story that
was I was like man yeah and I emailed
Chris the next day and said dude you put
a mic drop on it and we're selling a car
yeah that's cool that's cool
you know that's exactly what happened to
me clear because I'm the spender
Sharon's the natural saver at our house
and what I realized was was that it
didn't all of a sudden one day I went
wait a minute getting rid of crap
doesn't mean I'm never gonna have
anything it just means I get to have it
later and I'm gonna pay cash for them to
save up and pay cash for it and so you
know you'll get whatever you want later
yeah as far as the car goes and pay cash
because you're living like no one else
and later you get to live and give like
no one else you'll be in that position
that's cool I did not know that the
smart money conference actually caused
that for one of our own team members
yeah there you go nothing that's used
because sometimes someone needs the
extra motivation and now we were kind of
debating on whether or not to do the
debt free scream but our stories it
matters to other people and help
motivate and that that's what I think
really helps is now there's different
mediums in different times of your life
that help just put you over the edge the
live events that we do just incredible
and I applaud those guys that do that on
their team and you know that's the thing
about smart dollars sometimes people
don't know that this is out there and
then all of a sudden their employer
provides it and it's just a light bulb
that comes on in it doesn't matter I'm
sneaking an ad in that's good
good job you can just fill in when I'm
out of town man that's great so for our
audience how old are you - I'm 27 I'm 28
perfect okay weld on you - I'm very
proud of you very proud to have you on
the team be part of our family you're a
sharp young couple and we're honored to
have you here
so very cool all right Josh and Claire
$70,000 paid off and a Cherokee
amputation 19 months baby they did it
making 52 little over 60 count it down
let's hear a debt free screen 3 2 1
right there man
right there oh hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show you are not a victim
you're not a victim of big corporations
you're not a victim of Wall Street
you're not a victim of capitalism you're
not a victim of wealth inequality you're
not a victim of racism you're not a
victim